well i have some very urgent news to
report you guys ready
yeah uh you got your urgent news hats on
because this is big stuff
this must be so important it is
important it sounds serious
yeah last week i was in the larchmont
area
of los angeles with uh our producing
deity uh god he's the man behind the
scenes who pulls the strings mr adam
sachs
we were at this meeting in a building
and it was a very listen this is going
somewhere important
i'm sorry we were in this meeting it's a
building meeting in a building in
larchmont
and of course everyone's socially
distancing there's not that many people
there we've got our masks on it's all
very safe
and then we realize there's a balcony so
we go out on the balcony
just to be able to breathe some air and
it's adam sax and i on the balcony
and we're on the third floor not that
high up on a balcony and i look down
and there's a young couple i want to say
a man and a woman i'm going to say in
their
late 20s maybe 25 28 29
and they've been standing there and
they're just looking up
and i walk out on the balcony and just
as they see me the guy says
catechism
oh this makes me so happy and i was on
top of this balcony like mussolini and i
was like
yes and they were like yay and then i
went kadakai
and they said katakai and like
i don't know it's nothing expresses the
power
ugh of a podcast more than that insane
moment
i mean we're in a pain this country has
so many problems
so many things to deal with you can use
this for good
and instead you use it so people yell
this thing at you
i could be distributing valuable
information yeah on how you can go to
certain websites to get the vaccine
where you can go
uh how many times you should wash your
hands i there's all kinds of good i
could be doing
instead i've spread this foolishness
across
where once the dean of the actor's
studio mr james lipton
i was at a dinner with him and he
pointed up to a painting of his wife
uh in the nude and wrote catechi as god
made her
and i said that and i'm obsessed with it
and then i sort of challenged people and
i've had
people since come up to me and yell it
at me
once at the largo theater through a gate
uh
and they yell it as if they've come up
with the secret word that will save the
earth
that's how they say it and this these
people were i think had seen me go into
the building and i think
they waited oh that's good they waited
and they were like he might come out at
some point and we've been told we have
to do this
that's dedication i applaud i i don't
know who you people are
you were in the larchmont area area but
uh god bless you
yeah you filled my head with delusions
and you're keeping me going for another
year